you know sellers don't for hip-hop read
92 3 baby you already know what it is
master after-party bootleg cavities a
damage we got a real special guest in
the building it's kind of a big deal
like super special there yeah sometimes
I'm just very small boy with kid I got
me a yoga studio yeah
she's hearing I'm here they're in LA in
America Mega Millions it's a beer man
yeah from Africa
Legos Nigeria yo shout-out to Africa man
yeah yeah we don't want to stop ignorant
member we really don't know too much
about ya Africa bro first of all it is
definitely different from any of these
okay well you've seen online I've seen
the Lion King a lot yeah so definitely
dim from that I love the Lion King far
far from that my god I love the Lion
King greatly greatly that's a great one
man so so so you're from Nigeria
obviously in Nigeria there's a whole
nother music wave and I know when I was
watching your songs but you got like 15
20 million video views on these records
man it's crazy
are you like the jay-z over there which
i think it's not whiskey still my team
on a little oh you know on the low-low
I'm some ways like billions of streams
it's nothing low about billion I feel
yeah I just like you know I'm a very
chilled person I'm very easy busy I just
like to learn music I just cheer them
vibe I'm very on serious guy trust me
I'm not
how did you get into music like
initially when did you start making
music yeah when I was 11 11 years old
and church in church yes my god that's
crazy
no people I love even know about that
boy so you started at church and then
and then what was the transition from
you because a lot of people start doing
the music thing in church what was the
transition from that to recording your
first record to put your vocals down and
into a session and actually really yeah
it was a long it was really just meeting
like like a big producer back then back
home name which may be our IP address in
peace you know when I meant
they just put me on that just gave me
beats I just hang out around the studio
for like a year I never could have one
song you know just watching people
recall it like watching like you know
stars come and go and just learning and
just waiting for my time so how were you
at this point I'm yeah I was about I was
about 11 12 things so I was I was
frequent down to about I was like 16
feast so your first like we're court
when you first record your first song
about 16 uh-huh I was 11 when I came
upon song together yeah that was I was
like for the church stuff okay okay yeah
you know but when I met ojb yeah we took
it straight to the ceiling with win with
with kid born whisky was born like I
would say I was whisky born I never ever
thought about this give one of the
kicker when they begin pull this kid mmm
I think I was a holla at your boy right
how that your boy was a record
I like supposed have not actually fast
money fast club fast money fast car it's
a song by mi-ok back home is a big
rapper back from big shout-out to a guy
he gave me a shot I just did a hook on
that people allow yo who's got kids and
then whisk it was that something like
you was already being called or was that
name you came up with I just came up a
guy there's nothing special of a message
but like it has guy whiskey times I
doesn't know why well you come home wait
well yeah we're making using insurance
and IRL I said here will you man how's
it feel blessed I feel blessed I'm the
Sun how does it feel you do come to the
state because you always had such a big
fan base here but like right now
clapping whaling or Drake got this huge
single out right now like what's the
energy like when you come off that plane
you get a show here all right - you know
I'm about to go and tell like next month
you know right after I put out this tape
I so I'm really excited to like get back
on the road so like um it's always crazy
and enjoy my shows man different from me
right now I'm on stage I'm a madman if
the tour gonna be in the u.s. yeah yes
I'm gonna talk to us is this your first
time no this is not my first time I
taught like three years ago he did okay
I told him I liked his ago but it's the
first time since you've been working
with Drake between opposition
dick how'd it go one dancing because you
know Drake has a reputation of like a
jack in people's whole hallway whether
you know if you like listen to his album
some might say he's at London I don't
like you know talk about another nice
play area next well I mean obviously
that you guys have a great working
relationship he's on your single you
were on one dance but how did that
initially you know kick off that
relationship I really just happened to
sceptile sceptile UK you know you played
in my music and like yo this guy isn't
this guy I jumped on her leg by remix
that was it so when you get that call
like do you believe it's Drake that gets
Drake like it was something it's great
it's not really like a big deal of my
you know I mean I think shout out to
Drake I'm a big fan of Drake Drake know
what excites wizkid like who would call
you
besides you're taking who would call you
to work with you that would excite you
just drag the look that you are you
gonna have to talk in that mic to me you
talk a real soft man we gotta get to
understand vocals in there yeah yeah
every Avenue vocals in it not like with
the artists that you know
whoa that's crazy I never when you
thought about that you know I don't know
like to me is just I just see everything
as a as a chance like every day as a
chance and a blessing to leave like you
know god bless you today sleeve go away
whatever happens happens when he doesn't
happen doesn't happen you have to force
anything you don't control or what is
already facing and what is gonna happen
so like just leave your life what is
wizkid do what do you do when your free
time do you play video games
you obviously smoked eternity we've
we've definitely established a weed
thing as soon as you got here yeah yeah
well I love I love to like you know I
love to chew by myself a lot i watch a
little lot of movies okay what's it like
like what's like what's your paper my
lovely shows as well like I just depends
on my mood if you like with last movie
song very careful ash the last movie I
saw it was just what you know was not a
movie I think it's a joke
Queen of the South I was watching
oh the necklace how much Alex really
random stuff bro breaking bad you see
Breaking Bad
yeah son long time you [ __ ] Breaking
Bad yes also a rabbit a devil done with
an Turkey
I didn't he knows his boy knows
something and I'm like that's the way
bright dude trust me brother very like
you know have a very short attention
span so I was like i order you man
I'm 26 26 okay student sticks I'm just
kicking it and I said and you're a
father too right I got two boys I love
so much three that's crazy man and if
this you're obviously so international
with it it's probably hard to spend a
lot of time with the kids mayhem and so
odd this is like this is one thing for
me right yeah I'm a big family guy right
when I don't get to spend time with my
family I feel I feel a little pain in my
heart right for that is still what keeps
me going well you can get what summer
that's their motivation master I still
motivation that's everything that keeps
me going so you still with the baby mom
Helen oh hell no how a meaning like that
help man doesn't know well now I realize
I'm a bad bad bad man who will I didn't
like that right you know like but you
know it was it wasn't like a situation
that was like Clan Delaney wherever I
was blessed by God by two beautiful boys
so I can tell he's amazing hey man yeah
we all got baby mama subra me it me and
me and damage each have a baby mama
though you know we do we have kids we
got patient we're not with them on my
kids 1100 sailed out a four year old
diary I'm 30
Oh Lord make me bootleg what my old
[ __ ] ass over here
Jesus I am family brother where's your
thought yes you're so young
yeah you're four years away relax with
kid right you're lying around owner you
right around the corner
and I remember when I was 19 well yeah
how okay so now that we've said you're
not a baby moms you know you're like an
international superstar which is
different I feel like like you you gotta
get like some of the best strange in the
world yeah I got really you know got
women things but I'm not gonna kick that
kiss and tell I just you don't kiss him
I just keep it low low I bet your DMS
are lit though I really like to link us
to them though that's a little bit bait
get ready for bother alert
yeah we're snowball that it was more I
don't I want to do that you know I just
keep it really simple if I meet a girl
we kick off nice if you don't I'm all
the guys that expected girl to like me
sir yes please well carefree so you know
for fun you watch movies what else do
you do man would excite you whoa hanging
out with family bro there it is yeah you
know hang out a family a teen and buy a
Gucci suit candied yam oh my god I don't
know where you just let me go me fat
fish okay thank you cook yeah I know
tell mom I can make noodles though like
ramen ramen - a cup of noodles that with
all right I give a regular news
hey so obviously I don't damn you never
been Africa right no okay so now your
first have been African we haven't been
there yet so if we come with if we pull
up to Nigeria yes to go focal whiz kid
yes what's the first spot we got a hit
with you minutes first spot hmm first of
all we're going to my house we're going
to your house to smoke some weed and
smoke some weed Kingdom I got two cooks
you got two cooks yeah
my king yeah my house sit down smoke
some weed loud music out speakers like
in the club if your crib I've everything
out so we smoke weed hang out and you
know eat some food hang out with some
pretty females then heat the club's a
night I go to like four or five close
out the club scene out there I go man
it's crazy so just crazy I stay in a
club to 9:00 in the morning in the
morning you sure you're older cool you
only smoking weed
trust me my brother all I smoke and I
drink a lot of you know water more water
to come out of the water coming through
yeah well you know like I just hang out
with my friends I like to have fun
sometimes to just leave the club Ubuntu
life is it safe to say you're the
biggest artist in Nigeria mm I don't
like seeing myself like okay is it safe
to say is it safe for someone else to
say that like if someone else said that
would they like you know be full of [ __ ]
like I don't know you're the only artist
I mean I know wale is Nigerian but he's
from Washington DC so yes yeah you guys
make music together so you know I think
a long time ago that's what's up man
what smell the artist you filling out
here right now
everybody man I listen to everything I
sounds good but how do you how do you
choose what you want to collaborate cuz
you know working with you it's not just
the easy feat you know you can reach out
to look like y'all jump on the track I'm
just a very like particular person I'm
like I'm a serious but I'm very
particular so like if I feel like I'm
not gonna sound good on that very good I
won't do it we can be friends for life
but that's just one I like to just keep
it real and easy-to-use
I'm originally looks like nothing forced
at all I can feel it yes I have to risk
it might be the most laid-back guy we've
ever interviewed you know you're super
laid back what out man no no you're good
no no we're gonna be yourself yo our boy
was saying that you and Ty dolla Zagreb
doing a lot of work yeah the job is
might not be putting out a whole project
together serious I'm serious cooking man
big shots my god record view and I got
Nick in the chamber they got like 20
records you and I got 20 records almost
turning red what is it about ty sounded
you like just a true artist and I just
get a stir together make music not doing
first listen to wherever beats and we
vibe to keep up be my type of beast on
my producers you know African [ __ ] like
we just Batman is a true true artist
development so we met we might be
getting a nice scare surprise
from both of y'all together
international tie okay and then maybe
you get Wiz Khalifa on one of those rat
likes to go get that to come back oh
yeah big bass huge BAE I want to get an
African bag and how can we can't go Mia
damage come DJ in Africa please you guys
can come up I want to I want to hear you
yell look we're gonna hold you to it
wicked don't know video this is a video
bring a real after party snack whatever
you guys wanna hold you today nice bag
enjoy so don't have any girls ready for
me
[Laughter]
no women ready for you yeah we'll see
listen favorite places uh you travel to
that you just love the gold bar bout to
hang out at around the world Africa okay
London you know lovely I'm liking
aliamanu you ever been to Atlanta yeah
biggest roof local Atlanta for like
three months
Oh like you nobody go to the Magic City
I was always a mighty city every night a
strip club guy did they know you were in
there or did you kind of look he kind of
slid through yeah I'm a lucky guy
sometimes you might just simple looking
one of my guys go I don't sleep on it
though I try to pull up on you funny
don't think anybody's gonna be there I
don't know man I feel like I yeah but
I'm a very very easy I'm just I'm just
on this this will take anybody once you
have a very nice guy I'm a very easy guy
by not very I don't I don't really minds
you know it's lit me well work you got a
new project coming out soon right yes
yes yes yes sounds from the other side
I'm very very excited about that that's
like you know I'm ready to put that out
because I have too much music I don't
know what to do it obviously you got 20
records were ty dolla sign yeah I know
definitely live that's just like on the
side yeah any more records with Drake
that haven't came out yet no no no no
you did him a favor he did you a favor
yes like you know there's a strict
business
business keep you moving yeah I can dig
it back to you
well shadow is okay wait to go to Africa
whiskey thank you for the India so
wizkid we're gonna go we're gonna come
to Africa we're gonna go to your house
and we're going to jam out till 9:00 in
the morning at the club
you're lovely Negro sir oh yeah we're
gonna you can goat meat goat me fry a
fish whatever you want just wake up in
the morning whatever you want
come on wait how you eat so we're very
much the very least we're gonna eat some
new de tonight you can make a mini
animals rulers I just order for a lot of
stuff and I just speak a little bit it
must be nice to do that because you know
like people leave like this for poor
people like us we got to pick what's the
one thing we just want to eat we want to
hear let me get a whole left side of the
menu use I'll try a little bit by the
way I used to never have options
right you see eat my breakfast put it in
the fridge go to school come back like
I'm gonna get the letters how long ago
is this about like I moved out of Cairo
and all like 15 okay yeah so when you
say it's a very I'm always there my
parents still live there they don't they
don't want your parents don't want to
leave to get them even I just got them
like a nice house and allow you we're
not leaving sad to describe to us cause
like I always feel like the ghetto here
ain't they know there's no like like the
gallery nice various like it's real
videos for fun for you forget about this
when I see when I Beck's we have cable
in the ghetto here yeah we able we look
at internet okay wow you know that's
interesting we don't have time again I'm
sorry do big soccer fit not exact a nice
yeah sports at all anything no not
sports guys music hmm okay I'm not
liable to movies I'm a very like boring
guys I just like to chill hang on me to
like make music make new friends yeah I
yeah I think strippers
ah you know neither he doesn't get
yourself I'm to be honest before
anything I think after I left Atlanta I
feel you there was a legendary how many
like message skipped us to be honest
like I you can't I like to go to the
club
Bam Bam bang hit the door and keep them
moving sometimes I'll go my teens get
them the strippers yeah yeah these guys
over here no disrespect to no strip a
day now me like no like I'm saying that
you got requests in Nigeria uh-huh you
don't akan just you go in I guess please
describe to me what is you put it like
that like what I do no idea
come on find out all right we'll safe to
say we uh we have a new president with
kids
yes we're gonna go hang out with them in
Africa you know what vidiian I don't
really was we got to go out there DJ
yeah I don't know what we're gonna play
besides Drake one dance thing is going
to download your whole by the crazy
thing is when you go to the club back
home fusion like would mask off by
future be something that get played a
night here in Italy like come on don't
let's not be ignorant like we are very
ignorant we're very very very yummy all
right my guy my guy is like you know I
mean like we have internet so like the
people are very very aware of the music
they get it immediately gets out and
well like what we love and what we love
to product is oh [ __ ] that's the we
lucky you know that's what they want who
is like your doctor born a boy that's
the mystery that's the B's that's the
people at the two-faced you know that's
what our people want to get but as our
music you know we appreciate other stuff
can get it wrong way but I've ever had a
rat beef like if they're like ever been
like wizkid beef with somebody else I
don't like to be some good guy here a
nice guy yeah I feel like I feel like it
would be more than just a rat beef I
don't I don't like the beef I don't do
these settlements last long word I will
shout out to whiz kid we look forward to
hearing the album fly glasses I love the
glasses for sure man keeping it fresh I
lost a lot more money than I could
afford but they look nice up saying that
my guys look really nice thanks
but yo with you I'm coming out um July
July sir
July 7th this is like your big United
days before my birthday you know you
know this is the oh man you out here in
the US we can Elvis birthday I know you
chill low-key but you got to turn up
like yeah yeah I got a I got like some
crazy time something crazy party little
party when we go that's when we'll be
there for the postage shot the whiz kid
man
we're coming to Africa very much ticket
now well it's only like $5,000 we're
gonna get out of here and go smoke some
weed outside so we don't get fired we
were going to try to smoke in here but
that's obviously against the rules yeah
so we're going to go outside and get hot
with Liz can we have don't do drugs
don't smoke we don't drink alcohol stay
in school
right let's introduce in a single with
drink before you go okay let's get into
this new song man go ahead yeah this is
my single come closer
shoutout to a Drizzy on it yeah with kid
we're ninety two three